Sam: Hello.
Jake: Hey, how's it goin'?
Sam: Pretty good.
It is the year 2016, it's a new year.
And with the new year comes new things.
Really, we're starting this new year off
by trying to figure out how to make a
360 rig and maybe even figure out what
kind of video ideas we can shoot with it.
Wren: Right?
Sam: That was crazy.
Sam: What happened...
What's happening Wren?
Wren: Uuuhhhh...
360 video is important because it is the content of tomorrow
and by tomorrow, I mean
kind of the future.
Sam: It's all about
holy crap there's so many people, it's gonna be really hard to find him.
So there's no way we're gonna get a thousand extras.
So you just have to go to place where there's already a ton of people.
I think we're just gonna have to straight up guerrilla shoot it.
Because...
you don't need an operator for that you
just need someone to hit record.
If you put it down and hit record and just like
walk away from it
people look at it going "Oh, it's a bunch of GoPros"
You know,
and not go like "Oh, they're shooting a video"
Wren: Five of 'em.
As you can see, it's literally just
3D printed rig  so that you put a GoPro in it
vertically, like this.
You know, like a vertical phone,
You get a lot of up and down but not too much left and right,
but that's ok if you have a lot of cameras looking
left and right.
Wren: Like let's go to the
the boardwalk on a Saturday or something
Sam: Yeah, yeah go to pier and just like take
the thing like *Extending Noise*
Wren: with the Advent of virtual reality this year and more
virtual reality headsets coming out in the next several years,
people are going
to start want to view content that they can be
immersed in, you know, content
that you can actually look around and see.
see what issues that the vast majority
of people do not have one.
Right now, the best experience is literally taking your
phone and looking around
that's ok what we're doing right now.
So now you can see that it has five GoPros here...
all pointed outwards...
Niko: Wow.
Nerd.
*Laughter/Crying*